well hello and welcome my name is Casey
Clements I'm a new joiner at continuum I
work in New York I come from the
financial world and don't have very much
to do with bouquet to be honest I put up
my hand to do this as a reason to learn
a new technology and I've been having a
lot of fun
basically so we'll start I'm going to
talk about first the what the why the
how and the who voce and before then
talk about the format that I want to
walk through in the demo talk a tiny bit
about interest rate swaps maybe and then
put together kind of the dashboard and
finally have questions so what is
bouquet okay actually is a photography
term that describes basically what you
decide to put into focus and what you
take out of focus in a picture so it's
basically this this interplay between
the background and the foreground and in
a lot of ways this term came from Peter
who really loves kind of like little
details about this and you know it's a
bit of a bit of an artist himself so
this picture sort of gives you some
sense of what it is there's a lot going
on in the picture and basically what we
use is visualization in some way that
basically decides to draw something into
focus so we can kind of some degree what
we are all trying to do kind of is data
scientists regardless of the domain that
you're in try to find meaning and find
essence out of a day out of a world it's
just kind of overwhelmed with data so
here you have a picture of the gallery
of kind of bouquet you can see this on
the kind of the main website and kind of
dive into any of these things and quite
easily reproduce these pictures a lot of
these ones are static when you jump in
there's a bunch of links at the top to
just server versions as well what I'm
trying to do to some degree in this talk
is to for the newcomer like myself to to
get one feeling confident enough to just
to dive right into something and start
playing around with it so as you can see
with a lot of these pictures they have
the same sort of commonality
as you saw or they're law in common with
the picture you saw before in the sense
there's a lot of going on a lot of going
on and you want to kind of draw
attention to little pieces of it so what
is bouquet with the capital of B well
basically it's an it's an easy to use
visualization tool that's basically been
built in such a way to explore large big
multi-dimensional data sets and quite
often ones in real time streaming from
different servers etc it's interactive
in the sense that the user themself can
play with these things and then see kind
of actions will happen in the background
we have quite a lot of control of what
happens based upon the users users input
and so it allows both a client side as
well as a server side you don't have to
run it this way so you can have Python
running in a static thing we're
basically just feeds up a large part of
the data onto the client and the client
can interact with it or we have a
different configuration which is kind of
where this was going in the first place
which has a a JavaScript side on the
from the client side and then a server
in the backend that can basically run
things they can do automatic down
sampling I can react to different inputs
and different questions that are being
posed by the user and then finally it's
an open source project so by all means
jump in it's relatively new it's under
pretty active development it's been
funded largely by continuum as well as
as the grant that came in from the
Defense Department as part of the X data
project so zero point nine point two was
released I think on like Thursday so a
lot basically has happened if you looked
at bouquet a year ago and you looked at
bouquet now you would see quite a
different product and for the newcomer
like myself what is almost arguably the
most important is how much Doc's are
available so the documentation both user
guides and reference guys have been
completely rewritten they are robust
enough that you can just jump right in
like I highly recommend jumping into the
getting started and the tutorials to
walk you through it most of the stuff
that I will be covering
largely is handled there like you don't
have to get well it's a shallow dive
basically you can dive in and you dive
into numerous levels without without
feeling you've gone over over your head
too quickly there's a set of new tools
to kind of interact with with the data
so you have ability to do a lasso or you
can kind of tie in zoom in on a specific
part as well as like a Polygram sort of
do that some similar thing there's kind
of a crosshair as you move along and
then the hover tool which I don't know
if anybody's seen this kind of stuff
allows you to basically when you're you
know sitting over top of a piece of a
piece of the graph itself so you know so
it wasn't available previous like theirs
they really use the hover tool for
things like a lot of tables or you know
glyphs that built up graphs and so you
hover over a certain country and it
would tell you something about that
country or there's another kind of
common example that's used by these guys
which is it shows the periodic table and
so when you leave when you go over it
it'll tell you all these different
details about about that about the you
know the particularly
now it has a shinier look and it also
has callbacks now for static things
which means that you can have
interaction without having a server
running in the background so you just
throw everything onto the bouquets out
of the JavaScript side and see it react
now so this as you can see is a very
very busy screen and this is just like
basically a small snapshot of all the
other players that are inside of the
visualization space they all look quite
similar a lot of them are doing really
cool stuff there's a lot of overlap and
so the question is sort of begged which
is why is poke a so a bouquet empowers
data analysts to rapidly create some
interactive web graphic and dashboards
over real large data datasets without
writing JavaScript so it's not quite
there yet and each time you see this
talk if you see me again in a year or
one of my colleagues hopefully like will
slowly have moved away even more from
JavaScript Whois bouquet it's as you see
it's really it'll be a small team these
guys are all from continuum
down on the left kind of outside of the
picture a little bit as Peter who kind
of really started that off but isn't
doing much coding anymore but the rest
of this team is doing fantastic work
Brian who's sitting down there you
probably everybody here's probably at
this point said hello to Brian
either to get themselves a free pie
dated t-shirt or to get their get their
badges he was the guy that was sitting
at the front by all means go and talk to
him he is uh he's a superstar oh he's
probably sitting in the room in the back
too sorry detective there too I've
ridden real I wasn't intentionally
sucking up to you back there I kind of
forgot okay so basically in order to
make in order to basically allow for
people to jump in at different levels so
this thing is basically aimed at data
scientists that are basing being able to
bang up something quite quickly as well
as people that you know if they build up
a tool that they really like and they
want to basically turn up the knobs and
make it cleaner and cleaner and cleaner
to allow for basically these different
layers it provides three interfaces
let's see I talked about it a little bit
yeah so I'm not gonna go into too much
details it's been spoken about before
but I'll come back to in a sec so the
general design of Boquete sort of sits
on these two in these two parts right so
kind of on the client side that there's
JavaScript library called Bo KJ s and
then there's the back end of this thing
which isn't which is in Python so the
way that all the peoples that are
sitting here primarily be working in
Python like for myself I previously
programmed in Java and before that I
programmed a lot and C and C++ and so
I've been moving to different
technologies so far I haven't done any
JavaScript myself or very very little of
it so I my job is always to produce
numbers I've basically been the meat
inside of applications that you know
someone else was doing the UI work and
someone else was doing at the backend
and to a large degree I've come and join
continuum to sort of fill out my stack
knowledge and move a little bit away
from finance as well and so some of the
stuff to be honest quite kind of scares
doing a lot of javascript work I find
the whole thing very easy to get tangled
up in the web or starting the weeds so
this this is kind of the product for me
to basically be able to run in and
discover data played around with the
thing without without quickly getting
caught up and finding myself up two
o'clock in the morning try to get you
know a picture in the right place now
you notice in the middle that I've
caught we've got the same JSON sitting
there and basically this is the
transport layer that's being used to
communicate between boquete and python
the reason I bring that up is because
because it's just JSON sitting in the
middle and bouquet j/s has been written
in such a way to kind of be a
self-sufficient JavaScript visualization
tool this means that you can write other
adapters to it and as long as you kind
of write to this to the JSON schema you
can plug into this thing with with our
with Scala with any number of different
libraries you know try other JavaScript
libraries themselves this is an open
source project which means that the
development of these tentacles sitting
on our left-hand side is really based
upon demand from other users if you are
one of these users and and you like what
you see and you want to basically
produce stuff that that coheres to kind
of what we're doing by all means jump in
so far the ARB okay stuff has we're
investing in that and as of the most
recent release is you can get your hands
on it and play around with it this is a
busy picture at the top right of it the
this high-level mid-level low-level
these are the different layers of the
interface that I was speaking about
before so charts is like the simplest
one in the world in the sense that
you're like I want a scatterplot so you
basically kiss a scatter and then feed
in X&Y the next one below is plotting
and to a large degree for those that are
familiar with matplotlib it fought it
feels a lot like it so you build up a
figure and then you basically take lifts
so like different images so you know
like circles and lines and put them
together and then lay them basically on
to the screen where the low-level is a
lot more can't even though
well at least my impression of it so far
has been a lot of the things that exist
at the models also now exist at the
plotting level so just gives you a
different way to kind of interact with
the JavaScript and with you know the
HTML canvas itself so just it allows you
to go deeper and deeper in particular
for the kind of the novice user like
myself where the models come in
particular is they make available to us
widgets so sliders and text boxes and
buttons and all these things you want to
build up you just basically grab them
from the models pack and then you can
lay these things out we talked about a
little bit more later on the
compatibility that's mentioned here is
that you know we now very much live in
an ecosystem where everybody kind of
plays well with each other it's it's a
different world than it was when I first
joined kind of the technology space and
so in particular if you have a bunch of
stuff in matplotlib you can just
basically take your plots and the
figures that you built up and then just
be like dot tube okay and whatever you
had that kind of was building up these
little pieces if you want to then serve
it up onto the web you can just
basically be to bouquet which is a
really nice way to kind of move from
existing things you have into a
different presentation layer finally the
kind of third configuration of this
thing is where you have a server in the
backend so all this really has is it has
a rest interface that allows you to
basically the user interfacing with the
j/s layer can then pass information back
to the server and then the server will
call out again to python where you can
react to what's going on and then and
then send this information back so
although this isn't this isn't perhaps
the way that you would get into it right
away this is I think to my feet my
feeling is where a lot of the coolest
things can really happen okay so when I
thought about this this talk and what I
was going to do when I sort of put up my
hand to it I didn't really know what I
was going to talk about or how to go
about it all I did know was that there's
a lot of really good talks so if you you
know type in YouTube in boquete you'll
find great talks from Brian
great talks from Peter from from a
little bit before and then most recently
from a woman named Sarah bird so Sarah
bird what worked in the in the NGO kind
of space in in the UK and I guess half
of her time now is still spent there we
kind of stole her to some degree I mean
we were really lucky that she likes ok
enough that we kind of she's added this
on her own and we were able to get a few
days of her time a week now so this is
she gave a talk at PyCon in in Montreal
this year and what she basically did is
she talking kind of a scenario a use
case whereby she was asked to do
something at work and she had to kind of
build it up and she's basically we're
gonna walk through of how one starts
from scratch and slowly builds these
pieces up so this picture right here
looks like something that that could be
from The Economist where it's clean it's
really kind of it's pretty you've got to
write you know picture up on the on the
right which is telling you a bit about
some part of the plot on the bottom they
got a slide or you've got all these
pieces that are going to kind of react
to each other and this came effectively
from I guess it came from her company
previously I think it's called activate
let's check that but what this is called
is basically watch she talks about a lot
about which is basically wanted water
sanitation and hygiene in Africa which
is a big big deal in the NGO space this
thing isn't created by by boquete so
basically what she did is she started
walking through this and the first thing
she did is like okay well let's start
from a plot so when she starts with here
on the left hand side she starts with
this then builds it up let's see the
kind of you know start creating it
pretty making these things prettier and
by the time she gets through this the
talk she's got this plot looks just like
the other one you're able to kind of
select I don't have a selection tool
that's coming she's able to select
various countries so in this case you
selected Morocco you see how it gets
highlighted
you can then hover over top of it tells
you some information you have tabs at
the top between water and sanitation
so you can kind of switch back and forth
between underlying data sets or if you
have a data frame of some sort and like
a certain number of the columns are
giving you data about water some of the
stuff's giving you information about
sanitation you could jump back and forth
and at the bottom you've got a slider so
make this thing see like basically how
things have gotten worse or better in
certain countries as you move along
anyways that's my plug for Sara's stuff
and I basically I'm gonna try to follow
a very similar format now so in the past
life what I did when I first kind of
left Vancouver where I'm from is as I
worked in trading at JP Morgan and so I
lived sort of in this place and I did
the exact same thing every day which
that came in the morning figured out
what craziness happened overnight and
what my new portfolio looked like which
was often chaos for anything that looked
weird we had to basically decide right
away the first thing was is this real or
is it not like did my models fall over
or is this something that actually
happened the market and so if you act
upon something thing that's real when
it's not you end up basically hedging
something that's not really there acting
upon fake data and losing a lot of money
but so I got basically got really good
at under pressure putting up fires
I'm not I don't really miss it I'll be
I'll be honest so I'm one of these
strange people who has kind of through
time jumped been really attracted more
and more into the into the technology
side and just got myself pulled that way
and you know whereas my wife he's
another always happy because I'm
basically just doing what I love
regardless of how much money it's making
me I just really really enjoy it so this
is what my desk looks like got six
screens the guy beside me had six
screens the other guy had six screens as
you might have imagined it was like 100
degrees there what else we go into
details of all these little tools these
are all specialized little tools these
little ones on the right are for trading
foreign exchange the stent machine in
the middle there has a little microphone
allows you to talk to brokers you have
screens so to go into Bloomberg but what
I really want to draw attention here is
that you've got plots that are basically
showing in real time
data moving around so the prices of
various things and then you've got plots
that are showing your position and then
allow you to interact with these things
in such a way to make putting new trades
in and to see you know to see the
relationship from the new trades to what
you had when you came in in the morning
and your existing trades so basically a
typical screen on any fixed income or
bond traders desk will look something
like this so what you basically have
here is a picture of a bond curve so
what I'm showing here basically is
one-year two-year five-year ten-year and
30-year different maturities so these
basically are different products that
have this sort of length to them and
together they form some perspective of
what the cost is of borrowing or lending
out at different different terms so what
you're seeing here is I can't I keep
kind of wanting to show a pointer but I
don't have one they show it basically
what it was it like yesterday so what
I'm what I'm writing here as close is
basically the prices as the time I
snapped and then what the prices are
live so these things will start moving
around up and down and then the
difference between them effectively it's
a very kind of simple mathematical term
is you get a sense of what was my
derivative you know what is my first
order change and the value of the of my
trade for the underlying itself so you
just got like you know DV DX times DX
and that gives me some sort of estimate
of how much money are making or losing
from this trade and so what I'm showing
on the bottom there is a little bar plot
which shows in each bucket so for each
type of type of trade or term in this
case how much money I'm making or losing
and at the bottom I'm seeing that same
thing in a table the table is kind of
bouncing around and each day I sort of
watch this thing it might depending upon
who I am this might be a primary screen
or it might be one of these six eight
ten screens that are floating around but
I'm always kind of keeping my eye on it
in particular what we care about in
trading is the differences in things we
really care about where we were
yesterday to today because we closed the
books we say how much money we had there
and then we moved to the next day right
so there's always this kind of arbitrary
point at which you say I stopped here
and then I started here and look at
differences between two things
okay so the challenge that I gave to
myself effectively was to try to
reproduce this working trading screen
using just Python so the idea was how
far can I go along this line without
having to break out right HTML or CSS or
JavaScript C okay so from here we're
gonna break out of the safe place and
see how Casey can do as a demo okay I
think I'm going to start with ipython
notebook I think here hopefully
everybody after spending three days here
has seen ipython notebook being used a
few different times when you type in
ipython notebook it basically starts by
default and wherever directory or what
you were when you ran this thing and so
whatever files are there show up here by
anything that looks like IP and B is
gonna be one of your one of your
creatures and you open this guy and
you're kind of good to go
so the first thing that you do in a
similar way again we're gonna sort of
live inside of the bouquet plotting
level so sort of in that mid level just
cuz then you have a little bit more
control of like sort of building things
up in pieces so the first thing you
basically do is you just call out to the
plot it so the tupa plotting and say hey
i'm either going to be outputting to a
file question - do I have this
no will I yes yeah I mean like I said I
basically just got into bouquet for the
first time really two weeks ago so I've
sort of been scrambling to put things
together and see how far I could get but
I'm happy to do that
absolutely and answer any sort of
questions about the finance side of
things about bouquet side of things you
name it okay so the first thing you
basically do is tell is tell bouquet
whether you're going to be outputting to
a file whether you're going to be
outputting to a Moute notebook or
whether you're going to be working with
the server
in this case we're just opening to a
notebook I opened it up and it says okay
cool
we're all loaded up so the first thing
I'm going to do is say oh I need some
data so as everyone kind of knows pen is
a good way to kind of grab data and be a
little bit of the glue layer sometimes
between where one enters data and where
one starts actually playing around with
it so I will say cue over so this guy
here effectively is where I took that
picture of the slide from and behind the
scenes here just whoops says show up on
the screen alright cool behind the
scenes what I've really just got is I've
got this yield curve so I'm basically
just gonna shift shock this thing with
with a two factor really really simple
two factor models so in reality you'd
have kind of prices being drove you know
thrown in by some sort of broker system
and maybe they'd be updating so what I
did is I just created my own and to
really click quick one I basically just
had two factors one basically tells the
curve to go up and down and the other
one to some sense tells it to slope back
and forth so and then I'm just calling
Rand over and over and over and over
over again so it's really as I said I
haven't put a lot of thought into this
but the idea is that you have this kind
of setup where I can just continue to
like calculate this thing and as you see
the live prices are what I'm calling
here the current prices update as to the
P&L numbers and then the plots
themselves are going to be moving around
a real time so as you may or man of
guess I don't know I've I've taught
finance a couple times and so this is
probably like the third fourth fifth
incarnation of me reproducing something
that looks like this and it's some sort
of different language so I've done it
now in in a vba I've done it in Java
I've done it in some sources of C and
I'm doing alright so we're gonna
basically try to produce something like
this so we start basically by bringing
the data in awesome so here's our data
it's like what the columns are gonna
look like it looks like the data we're
looking at there before this is awesome
it means that we have access to some
live data and some current data so it's
the current sorry the closed data which
is yesterday's data so in boquete
plotting as I said before you basically
start by just saying I want to figure em
and it's really just giving you some
sense of a frame on what you're gonna
start drawing on and then the idea with
with bouquet plotting is again you have
lifts right so the line is the most
simple one and so we're the first thing
we do basically is we have a data source
which again is a really nice thing about
bouquets that you can just plot directly
to a panda's data frame well I thought
you could at first and so I tried out
and it says ok no you can so we're
basically one step away from this to be
honest whether it's changes the next
time I come back or not we'll see but
what instead happens is it's like well I
expected a data source and instead you
gave me where'd that go yeah sad you
gave me and it's arts printing this
thing out so basically pandas when you
print out the data frame instead of
saying I want to date a frame we're
giving the type it just plots itself out
so it says instead you gave me this
garbage which I don't know what to deal
with so instead all you basically have
to do is take a snapshot of it so inside
of bouquet they have another data frame
sort of like I mean if you're gonna like
learn something honestly out of you take
away from data science or what's going
on sort of in this kind of community if
you're really going to like if you want
to like get a get a get a good job and
do something cool and build cool stuff
what seems to be taking over right now
the kind of the paradigm is data frames
and the ability to kind of jump between
all these various languages whether it's
spark whether it's are whether it's
Python
our data frames and to be able to really
work with these things and work with
these things efficiently is so important
the number of times that basically I go
into a different consulting gig and I do
everything basically just by rewriting
how they've manipulated pandas is is
remarkable writing brain and good pandas
it's gonna always always gonna be the
guy saving the day so what basically we
have here is the same idea it's a column
data source you still have access to
basically a table of some sort that you
built up but it's a snapshot so it
doesn't have all the full functionality
of Penance you know like you've heard in
other talks today you know I'm not going
to rebuild the entire API of pandas
again we just slowly building up P build
up pieces as they become necessary or
you know we're to solve what we want to
solve so I've heard this now in the desk
Talk I've heard it everywhere which is
like try things out and I kind of see
what you need so instead I build up a
data source and then I say okay the
source is actually this column data
source so the exact same calls I did
before
I just had to make that thing into a
data source and then finally like in
matplotlib I show it cool so now we've
gotten to got our first block so this is
our hello hello pandas sort of deal and
then similarly I could take the same
plot and then I'm gonna add to it some
circles same idea exactly and like ok
cool now I've kind of thrown some
circles under this thing and so you know
it's starting to look a little bit more
professional I can see out of this thing
kind of where are the pieces that matter
to me and then I keep kind of going
along so that's the first line I've got
and again always using the same plots
I'm continuing to add onto the same plot
I'm drawing more pieces because I take a
lot of advantage of data frames so I'm
basically I'm still adding to the same
source so I'm always just reference back
back to the same source I'm just
basically saying colors very simple
colors I'm just being like I want it rad
I want it blue and then ok cool so now
I've added oops now I've added to it
your second lines so I've got a little
plot I can second move this thing around
anybody that hasn't seen a bouquet thing
yet all these things are sort of
automatically built in so you can kind
of pay
and you can zoom back in and back and
forth you can play around with the axes
by scrolling where the axes are which is
all kind of really useful especially as
you have like bigger data than we have
here reset this creature save it yeah
you can box oom on these things I mean
I'm probably showing pieces that have
you know everyone's already seen before
but if you haven't there at all is these
are all the kind of standard centered
pieces of what you get so to some
degrees these are kind of the one part
of the interactivity probably not the
most the coolest stuff you know some of
the Ector you know it's really when
you're pushing stuff back these are just
things I guess they get pushed back too
they don't ever go back to Python is
that right Brian is that same sense so
basically when you do these types of
interactions they're really just going
back to this they stay on the client and
render in j/s its again yeah cool ok
cool so now once we've got the other
pieces now we can kind of tailor this
thing to our preference right so in fact
instead of just calling it with the
default arguments I can add labels I can
you know say the size of it that I want
to you know I can add the colors that I
want here so I can go through palettes
and start taking pieces out and I can
start building up something that's
slowly starts to look you know a little
bit more professional sorry I keep kind
of without thing about just scrolling
around which is more a function of being
inside of the notebook than anything
else
so you know now I've chosen the colors I
know that I have outlines that are
slightly different than the colors and
interior I am certainly not a designer
as I said before I'm not a JavaScript
guy in our designer but what I do care a
lot about is numbers and getting them in
such a way that I understand them and I
can see differences okay so we got there
we got our first plot now it's kind of
sitting there and decide we can do
something basically the sack same thing
for for our bar plot so in this case we
use a glyph called a rectangle or rect
one thing all the only kind of
difficulty here that I had when I first
did this was to figure out what erect
was again now the docs for this are
fantastic so you can quite see
right away why it is that my rectangles
sitting in the wrong place so when you
have the X and y for a rectangle that
just says exactly where the middle of
the bar plot is so in this case what I
want is I want the bottom of my plots to
be at 0
I want the tops to be here the P&L
whether positive or negative and so I
just have to basically do you know
define where the midpoints going to be
which is going to be halfway between so
that's all that's going on there now
I've got my my you know plot okay so so
far I'm just basically building up these
things in a static way so really right
now I'm focusing on I think this is
probably the typical use case which is
you want to build these things up slowly
just by making them look the way you
want to look and then afterwards we
start you know turning them on and
making them dance okay so so far all
I've had to do is basically live inside
of the plotting module and what for me
at least what I need to do to go into
models force is to grab hold of widgets
so as I said before sliders text boxes
buttons etc but very recently a really
nice table has become become available
which is nice because when I first
thought I was gonna have to do this
having seen the periodic table before
having seen that the Africa picture I
thought I was gonna have to create a
scatter plot so it's very easy to make
easy to make a table just by basically
creating squares drawing things into the
squares and then creating them like a
scatter plot just saying where all the
squares are going to be throwing these
things in but now for the lazy guy like
myself there's a data table that's
available so I define what's in the
columns again refer back to my data
frame which makes it really nice and
easy
I say can I scroll over here yes awesome
so I say that I want to have things
pretty looking so that you know numbers
come out with comma separators etc and I
have percentages I don't have point 0 0
0 is all these for my differences and
then you get it pretty nice to be honest
this doesn't look this looks nicer when
you'll see it later on as HTML than it
does come out inside of inside of the
notebook but you have these things kind
of pretty and you they'll move and they
jump around so without having to do any
work really I've got a data frame I can
push this thing down and I've got my
plots now I guess the next piece is that
so far I basically just have created
these three objects and they sit they
sit around and being someone that
doesn't really know HTML I don't know
how to put a box over here in a box over
there and I'm not just saying that for
demo purposes like I don't and every
time I go into JavaScript I sort of
forget and after we kind of learn it and
like everything else I personally just
takes somebody else's existing code and
then just refactor it for myself
so instead what we have here something
that's really useful for someone who's
trying to put something together really
totally quickly or easily which is you
have these two kind of boxes so you have
an H plot and a V plot as you might
imagine one of them's horizontal and one
of them is vertical so it allows me just
to stand pieces into I can throw things
together and I can actually put an H
plot inside of a V plot so I can have
you know two things that go down this
way and then and then another little
rack that has little pieces inside of it
that way and for my purpose largely I
can make decent tables of different
things just by putting together V plots
and H plots and of course the caveat to
this and this is pretty important to
know that once you have something
running and you've got this thing
producing the pictures that you're gonna
we're going to you can jump back out you
can ask your friend you can write very
little amount of JavaScript to make it
look that extra amount prettier so it's
all very much part of the 8020 rule
about how far you want to get and you
can continue obviously to make this
stuff prettier and prettier just how
much time and effort you have to throw
into it so what I've just basically done
is taken these three creatures that we
just built
threw them into a vertical box and said
hey show so it basically stacks these
three guys together and we're kind of
good to go so as you might recall this
is what we're trying to produce
something it looks like this and we've
kind of got it so far I mean this is
just in a bouquet in the notebook and I
literally built it up here but to be
honest I built it primarily and just in
in van and just kind of threw it back
and forth so this was just for you guys
purposes so let's jump shall we
and I want to do that okay so does it's
not bad you guys can see it in the back
yeah awesome
okay so basically when you jump now to
making this thing do something fun
basically I'm going to create something
called a piano dashboard and I'm saying
it's very similar to what I did before
so instead of saying I'm going to output
to a notebook in this case I'm just game
an output to its server and what that
allows me to do is produce callbacks
which means that you know on some sort
of action from the user
I can react to that thing do some call
some Python code you know whatever
user-defined Python code I want and then
push that thing back and act and act
upon this thing I can redraw funky
things I can put different plots and I
can do quite a bit actually and then you
know prettiness aside you know I have a
lot of a lot of a lot of flexibility
now one other fancy thing that I did or
I got help from the team from was in
order to in order to fake this idea of
having live prices that are floating
about we just basically did a little
running thread so I basically have a
thread that just runs through here this
guy and it's just has a while loop
that's wiling on true and so I'm just
calling the same thing before that you
saw in the excel piece I'm really trying
to make it seem as similar as possible
so I have two factors that I'm just
taking draws from my volatility and I'm
multiplying it from and then in this
place I've created like a mean reverting
process so that the plot doesn't run
away too much on me and then I'm just
updating it through these pieces here so
in the real world you're gonna have data
streaming from a broker site or from
some sort of sign it's going to keep
feeding data to you in this case I'm
just updating it so the original table
that you saw the live prices I'm using
this to kind of update these prices and
I can run this thing in the background
and then just pull it and just ask it
what it's doing all the time so that's
effectively what's happening down here
in the current session and there's a
similar example
in the original examples called I think
it's called animated and it's this glyph
and just has this rotating cliff so
you're very similar get your hands on
this kind of stuff and play with it in
different ways
take a look at the thing called animated
and it just has this kind of really
clever looking like rolling plot okay so
let's see what I wanted to show it to
you guys so so all I basically do here
the first thing I do is call run so I
start up a data frame by just calling
and to get data what does get data look
like really simple see right there it's
right there so my get data is magic
basically I just say call pandas and say
hey read an excel file I'm skipping over
the footer just because I don't want
everything that's in there I want that
one line to get stripped away and then
that's it so now I've got my data frame
I create another separate data frame
which we'll talk about later and then I
call create and I create method
basically what I'm doing in order to
maintain state I've just basically
created a few global variables and that
will allow me in this case when I press
buttons and do various things to kind of
update that state and keep it there for
later on when I do the callback so
because I tried to do something that
hadn't necessarily been done you don't
see that a lot of the examples at you
see I'm bouquet have a lot of widgets
they've been really working on these
widgets to make them look clean and
pretty so I was like no no I want to
have something that's running in real
time plus I want to play with it plus I
wanted to do this so they're like okay
well we can probably do that and we
haven't tried it before but we can do it
and it worked which is I'm really
excited about actually I didn't think
we'd be able to get this whole thing
running but we did so in the meantime we
got this global state it's kind of just
sitting around just like a lot of this
code I showed before you before so I
create a data source out of the pandas
dataframe I create my plots I create my
data table and then this is kind of new
stuff so basically everything's there so
the key
really at this point is that I got a
thread that's running in the back it's
going to update my live stuff and then I
created a server so that servers going
to basically continue to pull it and
just ask it what it's doing oh I might
come back to that so to run boquete
server that's pretty straightforward you
say broke a server all the stuff you get
from Conda it's kind of pop that guy
open oh wait I have to kill it
sorry the reason for this primarily is
because I'm a bit of a procrastinator
and I've been doing a lot of talks here
it's this week so I haven't kind of got
everything in the best of States let's
see cool okay so now we've got this guy
running in the background I can then do
there's numerous different ways to call
into this you can call scripts a lot of
the stuff is worth taking a look again
the documents are there now which is
fantastic so Brian and his team did
something quite clever which was instead
of answering the same question a
thousand times on forums etc to actually
just write the answers down and write
down as many different ways that they
can so people can go there first and
when someone says hey how do you do this
you they say okay read that which I did
primarily okay so I've created something
which now and his version is called
piano dashboard pops open it'll
automatically you know throw this thing
up inside of
here we go so this thing will throw
itself up into my browser open it up and
start running this creature so see for
the screens purposes we now have
reproduced this guy so realistically
this is me as has been my I have a day
job so I did this kind of on the side is
for fun for this talk and I'm relatively
happy with it so I'd be watching this
thing during the day price is moving
around maybe not quite this volatile but
in today's markets it's not completely
unlikely you have a nice-looking
maturity again all this has been done in
such a way that I've done no Java
scripting at all and for someone like me
I can take that I can put the window put
it aside on a screen it owns a piece of
real estate on my trading screen and I'm
relatively happy and this is honestly
ten hours work that got me into a place
where I've got a screen that's used all
over the world you walk onto any trading
floor and everyone's got caught
something it's gonna look just like this
now in order to make it even a little
bit shinier I wanted to continue to play
around so I then said let's bring some
widgets into it and this this part is
really quite experimental not
experimental on the bow case I have it
experimental on my side so basically
what I've added here is for fun is I had
a button I added a select box and I had
a few text boxes and these are very just
widgets I then like I said before I put
them into an H in H Box H plot and then
I added that H plot into my V plot and
then underneath it I said okay I'm going
to create a second table now this table
below it here obviously looks like just
like this one and the idea is what
you'll usually have is a set of trades
or at least a position I mean so what
really happens here for traders purposes
is that these aren't each a single trade
what these are is the aggregation of all
trades underneath these buckets or more
explicitly they'll give you some sense
of the position so it's like if I bump
up the one-year point in my curve and if
you have a trade that has like
some sort of sensitivity to that point
it will then be part of the aggregation
to that point so you be you know you
might have a swap so I'm sort of funky
swap that actually buckets into all
these different maturities whereas so
this is basically my existing positions
and it could be a very large portfolio
but if I'm only trading on one curve in
one currency then I'll actively have
something looks like this but then
during the day I might want to make
hedges to basically capture some of the
profit to cut off some of the profit if
these things are options and they have
kind of some sort of nonlinear position
means as the underlying moves the
sensitivity will change as well so all
off to make trades so what I decided to
do to to make kind of more realistic was
the ability to kind of make changes into
this thing and then add new trades and
so this really was me just kind of
playing at the last minute but you call
this creature and we got it to work
where basically it starts adding in and
creating new tables and I just start
adding rows so I have the ability quite
quickly to kind of build something up
and it's pretty dynamic I'm pretty happy
with this thing the code for that yes
just to kind of show at the end is I
basically created it see
yeah so basically for these new widgets
all the way at the bottom yeah it's for
the for these new widgets here I
basically just said I have a to deck you
know texting inputs select I have a
button I said okay I want an event on
this button I'm gonna call this click
it's gonna call this function right here
and then when I look for that function
that's not what I was trying to do but
it did take me to the right place and I
can write my callback function so as we
were saying before I have an event and
then on that event it's gonna call back
I can write whatever I want in here in
this case what I'm really doing is I've
created a second data frame calling data
source and I start building it up but
new prices new maturity is this heading
and build this thing back up and then
it'll start getting pulled again so the
next time that it then pulls in this
thread that's running it may be like oh
hey this thing's bigger and I'll just
start plugging this thing up there are
many different ways to skin this cat but
it's definitely something that for
someone like myself we knew nothing
about it the takeaway is that it's easy
to jump in to get your hands dirty and
play around when you bump up into
trouble then send us emails and
hopefully Brian hopefully I will
actually be able to help answer them so
that out of this talk I don't just
basically get 50 new people that are
just asking inundating inundating the
team with questions I will do my best to
help question oh yeah I fixed it yeah so
I basically fixed it between I think
minus 50 and 50 thousand when you have
it updating it really looks very
volatile and when you have it that way
when you think about it this way like
the PNL if you're actually looking at
that would make no sense right cuz if I
just if it always just kind of stay
there if you just had one and then you
just see this thing floating so hard
that's okay if you only have one thing
you're looking at but if you have
numerous things then very confusing
shoot
so again
yeah sure that's a good that's a really
good question and so I mean I'm really
telling this story and this is a story
it's a use case from my perspective as
someone that's that's not you know it
doesn't doesn't want to get too deep
deeply into JavaScript but the reality
is that Bocage is is a full functioning
javascript library to do all the
rendering that this thing's going to do
you end up building it up somebody's
writing JavaScript and then there's what
we're finding common patterns that are
happening and with those common patterns
with yes you're you know pulling them
out into Python so that you can get
access to them without having to write
the JavaScript but by all means you can
write your own JavaScript you can then
you can do pull requests back into the
J's library you can you can basically
jump down and up so I mean this thing
has been structured in such a way that
it really is architected these different
levels where that's a good point
implicitly I was talking about charts
plotting models but then there's Bocage
AAS and all the stuff that you can do in
there does that answer your question
go ahead gentleman in the yellow yeah
yeah well that's it right I mean just to
say just to say you did it but then also
it's it's it's pretty it's a pretty
useful thing I mean I don't know if
anybody I don't West Coast is slightly
different than the East Coast but I mean
in New York everybody seems to work in
some way or has worked in finance
especially if you want to make decent
money and there's been this ongoing
battle I mean I'm probably in the wrong
place to say it I'm it's a bit sacrilege
but time it's maybe a bit sacrilegious
but I mean there's been an ongoing
battle to try to get away from Excel in
some way I mean you were so tied down to
Excel so it's like I want to be able to
build things quickly and in something
some sort of other application layer
anyone at any application there and the
browser is becoming that they'll take it
offline okay cool
awesome thanks Brian thanks guys